more than 93 million Americans are obese
and millions more are overweight that's
according to the CDC but a recent study
from the Cleveland Clinic shows few are
doing anything about it 74 percent of
the people surveyed say they are
concerned about their weight and 65
percent say they worry about getting
heart disease because of those extra
pounds but fewer than half have tried to
change their diet and less than a third
of talk to their doctor about it
Samantha Heller is a registered
dietician at NYU Langone health center
she's here with scientifically proven
ways to lose weight good morning to you
Samantha
good morning so the study shows that
people worry about being overweight but
they're not doing enough about it why
well I think there's many reasons one
reason is I think sometimes we don't
know they were overweight or obese we
think of may not have a mirror how would
you not know that you're overweight well
I think we think you need to be hundreds
of pounds overweight for that to fit
into that category but in fact it's not
at all
and if you look at a BMI of body mass
index chart and you look at your height
in your weight you might be surprised
what category you fit into so I think
that's one thing that people really need
to pay attention to go through so let's
go through these mcclee how important is
your diet compared to exercise when it
comes to weight loss diet is everything
diet is more as as much as I love
exercise and I know you do too diet is
everything it's not only how much you
eat but it's the quality of the food you
eat that's gonna make people take
calories in calories out do you believe
that yes there's truth in that but I
think what you eat makes a difference as
you know when you can lose weight eating
cake but it's not healthy so we want to
create a sustainable dietary pattern
that we can keep for the rest of our
lives that include all the healthy foods
to help our bodies keep us healthy and
fight disease you encourage people to
look at favorite foods in a new way
macaroni and cheese staple and
everybody's household what can you do
well instead of buying it in a box with
a powder packet although it tastes good
make it four make it from scratch at
home and you can do things like what I
do if I'm gonna make it I thought when
I'm boiling the water for the pasta I
throw in some cauliflower I cook it till
it's Kent tender I take that out i puree
it so I'm gonna make that into part of
the sauce to make it creamy but it's got
all those healthy compounds that
vegetables have it's got flavor so you
can boost it up and add vegetables
really you can add these non starchy
vegetables to anything and make it
healthier for you a lot of people know
that they have issues with their weight
but you know life is busy there
a lot going on and so sometimes when
they hear this advice it's kind of
hectoring and they're you know so what
is the kind of trick or key turning
point for somebody who knows all these
things intellectually but still has this
barrier I love the idea of people seeing
registered dieticians because he or she
can help individualize the plan that's
gonna work for you and what you do is
gonna be different than what Nora does
right and different than what I do or
what Gayle does so that's an option and
insurance does cover some of that but
also make a plan sit down with your
family plan what you're gonna eat during
the week that's gonna help you avoid
food waste save money it's gonna get
your kids and your family involved in
the shopping and the prep for the food
have a plan but the insurance piece is
important because a lot of people may
not have the money for that but so the
dietician can be covered by insurance
some dietitian services can be covered
by insurance excuse me insurances some
dietitians might work on a sliding scale
for you so I mean it's a great
opportunity there's classes but it's
like we're going to make the point that
one size does not fit all I think he
might think if she's doing well or he's
doing well I need to do that and you I
do think you have to stress it you've
got to figure out what works for you
what works for you because as I said
what I do for me it's gonna be different
than what's going to work for you it has
to take into account your budget your
food preferences your lifestyle a lot of
questions I get intermittent fasting
does it work
we're already intermittent fasting when
we sleep most of us don't eat during the
night so that's great there's no one
kind of intermittent fasting there's
many different iterations
I like the idea perhaps of closing the
kitchen after dinner and some people say
they'll meet between certain hours so
after dinner when you've had dinner a
lot of people sit in front of the TV or
the computer and they eat their chips as
Lopez is recommending the no carb no
sweet diet for 10 days and I'm actually
thinking about doing that okay I think
your time would be better spent the
regular visits with the dietician this
is my big thing yeah we spend more time
getting our hair and nails done the way
your health professionals what if we
spent the same amount of time going to
dietitians nutritionists cancer
specialists skin doctors you know all
that they're saying I gotta go but like
this is like my new thing
getting everybody
you know [ __ ] don't do it okay we'll
be right back sorry at the time it's so
good